you or someone you care about may have
been diagnosed with ckd anemia or anemia
due to chronic kidney disease
this video will help you understand more
about ckd anemia and how it affects your
body
anemia happens when you don't have
enough red blood cells
red blood cells are made in the center
of bones called bone marrow
in red blood cells iron is needed to
make a protein that carries oxygen
called hemoglobin
red blood cells flow through the
bloodstream to the lungs to pick up
oxygen
as blood flows through the lungs
oxygen moves from air sacs into the
blood
then
oxygen attaches to the hemoglobin in red
blood cells
these red blood cells deliver oxygen to
cells throughout the body
cells need oxygen to function and
survive
in anemia there are not enough healthy
red blood cells to deliver oxygen to the
body
this means that organs and tissues may
not work as well as they should
while many conditions may cause anemia
it is often caused by chronic kidney
disease
the kidneys make a hormone called
erythropoietin or epo
bone marrow uses epo to make red blood
cells
chronic kidney disease damages the
kidneys so they don't make enough epo
as a result
bone marrow makes less red blood cells
causing anemia
symptoms of ckd anemia may include
feeling tired or weak
pale skin color
headaches
problems concentrating or thinking
loss of appetite
chest pain
a fast heartbeat
feeling light-headed when you stand up
and shortness of breath with activity
a doctor may test a sample of your blood
to see if you have ckd anemia
for example a complete blood count test
can measure the amount of hemoglobin and
red blood cells in a sample
a normal hemoglobin range in healthy
adults is 13.8 to 17.2 for men and 12.1
to 15.1 for women
a low hemoglobin level in chronic kidney
disease is below 13 for men and below 12
for women
your doctor may perform other tests to
evaluate ckd anemia
if you have questions about ckd anemia
when to start treatment or any
medications you have been prescribed
talk to your doctor
it is important to take your medications
as directed and report any side effects
you have
this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or nml where
you can download this animation and
thousands of medical images and videos
created by nucleus medical media to
apply for a free 30-day trial click on
the link in the description
you